[Musique]
oui mais la parole de m6 limite sa mort
lundi puis alors cette semaine jean
lefer une prenait très légère priape la
vie parce qu'on est le mois de juin le
mot de l'histoire des peuples
autochtones mais aussi en route vers le
21 juin qui est la journée nationale des
peuples autochtones
aux gérants deux événements que deux
occasions
de pouvoir non seulement profiter
ensemble lire justement des artistes des
artisans rectum mais de pouvoir en même
temps commencé quand je veux ouvrir la
porte plus grandes que le mois de juin
pour pouvoir avoir en fait les cultures
des peuples autochtones dont on célèbre
justement
le des peuples fondateurs du canada pour
pouvoir se rendre compte que des fois on
n'est pas toujours énormément présent
donc
avec les deux suggestions je vous parle
je veux vous également découvrir plus à
augmenter la demande et va donc ouvrir
la porte à des jeunes créateurs puissent
se dire justement qui ait de la place
pour eux sur ces plateformes donc mon
premier événement c'est en juin je lis
autochtone dont l'initiative a été
lancée par la librairie et les maisons
dix ont un impact ça se passe en ligne
mais ça se passe aussi dans une
quinzaine de librairies participantes ou
est-ce que sur place vous pouvez voir
justement la littérature l'écriture
autochtone mis de l'avant que livrait
aussi il ya des événements tels que les
balades du trickster aucun peut
participer et c'est une bonne manière de
pouvoir découvrir non seulement des
auteurs autochtone du québec me direz ce
candidat parce qu'il faut pas oublier
encore un enjeu où
beaucoup de la littérature autochtone l
interaction qui est publié de l'anglais
au français puisque
il ya encore beaucoup à développer sur
l'espace public de comment je peux dire
d'imaginer pour se dire qu'on peut avait
publié qui sont d un jeune autochtone je
donne souvent l'exemple de ma cousine
rita mestokosho qui est une des
premières pour et est publié en français
en hymne aux moines au québec et les
pactes devons justement que les gens
invités à venir faire des lectures la
publier
salon ouvert une porte ou est ce
qu'avant on avait l'impression qu'il y
avait pas on pouvait pas et le podcast
pour nous et nous voulait pas dans ces
endroits là mais de plus en plus
d'artistes je parte en acheter un
attaché canapé fontaine et à beaucoup
d'autres qui est là justement l'entrée
de la porte de ses auteurs est de plus
en plus justement l'espace va s'ouvrir
mais un mois en juin par exemple je vais
me remettre à la lecture de marot fives
de chéri des malaises qui
devient vraiment à fun autochtones au
futurisme
ça se passe justement d'un futur ou
intelligents ont perdu la capacité de
rêver il se rend compte que les
autochtones ont encore la capacité de
rêver et je peux je veux trop vous
vendre le punch qui s'appelle quand même
le voleur de moi le fait que
j'aimerais ça qu'il y en ait de plus en
plus qu'ils soient écrits parce que
c'est un genre littéraire que j'adore et
de le lire dans une perspective de
personnes autochtones ça devient autre
chose donc le mois de juin en juin je
dit autochtone et un autre événement que
je veux vraiment mettre l'avant c'est
justement coin à la rencontre des
peuples autochtones qui se passe à
québec sur la place jean béliveau ça va
avoir lieu du 16 au 19 juin donc des
artistes des artisans de la dégustation
des restos en direct des restaurants à
bois ou est-ce que vous pouvez manger
justement des savoirs autochtones
réputation et beaucoup d'évènements qui
vont être l'avant justement une
rencontre qui peut se faire en vrai
maintenant près de deux ans où le
festival peut plus faire de rencontre je
mens
à québec d'ailleurs moi pas qu'une
matrice de quick oui je vais y présente
le
le 18 pour enregistrer la dernière
émission de la saison
justement sa place alors je suis
extrêmement excité d'aller au festival
mais vous comprendrez que c'est
fantastique de pouvoir célébrer son
identité en dehors d'un mot précis mais
je tenterai comme tout le monde que ce
soit pour le 21 juin le 24 juin ou le
1er juillet l'avoir l'occasion d'avoir
une journée pour le célébrer c'est
important mais de pouvoir justement
avoir d'autres mamans pour de l'année où
elles sont on peut ou justement soutenir
les aspects positifs culturellement est
positif mais musicalement aussi de notre
identité c'est aussi quelque chose qui
est qui qui renforçait qui les antiques
est justement à la réconciliation donc
j'encourage beaucoup parce que ça va
développer un marché ça va développer
après le marché ça va développer une
demande et la demande lb ça va être le
pouvoir que les jeunes ont de se faire
entendre à des personnes autres acteurs
aussi des auteurs qui aurait écrit car
en parle qui pourront peut-être même ce
pu faire publier mais entre gens n'ont
pas de montillot pensais pas pouvoir
écrire qui commence à écrire maintenant
qu'ils sont bd des adultes alors c'est
important de pouvoir ouvrir plus grand
ses portes pour les clodettes alors je
veux mais sereine et j'espère qu'on va
se voir justement à ces événements